[Musique]
le nouveau préfet de la Réunion Jérôme
philippini a rencontré ce mercredi les
pompiers du 1974 à la caserne de la
possession en présence de Cyril Melchior
président du Département je voulais
venir peu de temps après mon arrivée
saluer les sapeurs-pompiers de la
réunion je sais leur engagement je sais
qu'ils sont très courageux ils
interviennent au jour le jour pour
sauver des Réunionnaises et des
Réunionnais et moi comme préfet j'ai la
responsabilité de leur demander de
s'engager régulièrement donc je voulais
venir les saluer dès que je suis arrivé
j'ai avec le colonel aiguillé qui est le
directeur du 10 fait le point sur les
moyens sur les équipes évidemment c'est
fondamental parce que chaque jour on
peut avoir besoin de demander aux
sapeurs-pompiers d'intervenir de même
qu'avec la police avec la gendarmerie
avec l'armée on est toujours très au
contact pour essayer d'agir le mieux
possible pour protéger nos concitoyens
le préfet a pu rencontrer Léon sapeurs
pompiers volontaires partis apporter
leur aide à leur collègue métropolitain
pendant les incendies en Gironde
le déplacement du point fr la possession
c'est l'occasion de dire aussi que les
Réunionnais ont apporté leur solidarité
lorsqu'il y a eu des grands incendies en
Gironde et bien nous avons eu donc des
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels de la
Réunion qui part qui ont décidé d'y
aller et donc cette solidarité dans le
sens réunion métropole fait suite à une
solidarité qui s'est exercée dans le
sens métropole réunion quand il y a eu
ces grands incendies très important donc
de montrer l'esprit qui anime le x 97 4
ont également été présentés à cette
occasion l'équipe de garde du groupe de
reconnaissance et d'intervention en
milieu périlleux ainsi que le fourgon
secours routier
[Musique]